ciao sono scappato da roma
quindici anni fa più o meno e per
inseguire appunto i miei interessi e le
sperimentazioni artistiche sono andato a
londra però curiosamente o in realtà
sviluppato un interesse fortissimo
proprio per l'arte classica e
l'iconografia classica quindi in realtà
quello da qui poi sono scappato in
qualche modo è diventato come se fosse
diventato un po la tematica principale
del mio lavoro degli ultimi 10 12 anni
infatti è proprio attraverso
un'operazione fotografica che ho
cominciato a osservare roma osservare il
posto da cui da qui vengo sono iniziati
questi studi fotografici sulle chiese
barocche romane ma l'intento non era
tanto quello di catturare il loro
carattere storico il loro peso culturale
loro contesto culturale ma invece tutto
al contrario una visione quasi
scientifica cercavo infatti un'analisi
puramente distaccata puramente
scientifica estetica sorta di studio
estetico infatti l'obiettivo non era
tanto quello di ricostruire delle
immagini come tali ma realtà di generare
degli spazi completamente digitali da
poter poi esplorare
quindi in realtà delle ricostruzioni
completamente digitali di questi spazi
per poter essere poi osservato in
maniera completamente diversa da come in
effetti possano essere osservati in real
life
quest'immagine per esempio non è una
fotografia è una combinazione di
centinaia di fotografie un oggetto che
diventa quasi una mappa clorata nel più
minimo dettaglio
faccio vedere ora un piccolo estratto
video appunto un'esplorazione un'analisi
visiva di questo di questo soffitto
per me il video non è mai stato
un'esperienza lineare non sono mai stato
interessato nell'idea di video come una
sorta di narrativa lineare o qualcosa
che ha un inizio e una fine
per me il video a un oggetto di
contemplazione e questo è proprio come
faccio vedere i miei lavori come vengono
installati sono in effetti delle degli
spazi immersivi sono interessato a i tag
del video come un oggetto che in effetti
va contemplato va esplorato come un
oggetto scultoreo e proprio questa
relazione con lo spazio digitale e
spazio reale o qualcosa che poi ho
portato avanti negli anni relazionandosi
con diversi spazi storici un po in tutta
in tutta europa ma in parallelo
oltre agli spazi sono poi insomma il mio
focus del mio interesse si è avvicinato
ai dvd alle opere e alle collezioni e
così con modalità simili ha cominciato a
studiare collezioni di musei dipinti
catturandone dati catturandone
scansionando lì a risoluzioni altissime
anche qui appunto poterci poi entrare
dentro nel minimo dettaglio come se
diventassero dei paesaggi da esplorare e
vi faccio vedere ora un piccolo estratto
video
questo è un altro lavoro in
collaborazione con il palais des beaux
art di lille in cui io ho osservato
tutta la loro collezione di rubens è
fatto questo
no
cosa per me affascinante di questo
progetto sarà poi l'opportunità di far
vedere il mio lavoro video
accanto agli originali e ne infatti per
me è molto importante non solo la output
generato dalle mie ricerche ma la
tensione che si crea con l'originale
proprio di questa tensione che alla fine
sento sento il bisogno quindi
l'importanza dell'originale questa sorta
di tensione temporale i miei video
infatti come dicevo hanno bisogno di
essere sculture hanno bisogno di essere
fisici ho sempre messo tanta cura in
come questi oggetti effimere digitali in
realtà vengano fatti vedere e
acquistando una loro tangibilità e
proprio per questo negli anni negli
ultimi anni mi sono cominciate ad
avvicinare all'idea di trasformare
alcuni di questi processi digitali
computazionali in oggetti fisici per
esempio qui un trittico generato dall
analisi di un dipinto di rubens e anche
qui come potete vedere c'è questa sorta
di tensione con l'originale cioè da una
parte come se fossero i due opposti
della nostra cultura visiva da una parte
c'è un dipinto ad olio figurativo
dall'altra un'astrazione digitale
algoritmica però in realtà questa
astrazione generata dall analisi dalle
regole compositive dell'originale come
se fosse una traduzione dell'originale
come se fosse un osservazione
dell'originale con un occhio diverso
l'occhio della macchina e infatti
proprio questo un po là la chiave del
mio lavoro
l'idea dell'algoritmo che guarda questi
oggetti d'arte oggetti di perfezione ma
in maniera disinteressata maniera molto
diversa da come noi osserviamo questi
oggetti occhio della macchina propone
una visione completamente alternativa
completamente staccata dal peso
culturale di questi oggetti da queste
narrative iconografiche e per me in
realtà questa è un'opportunità un
opportunità di riscoprire di guardare
magari oltre le nostre quello cui siamo
abituati in qualche modo un'opportunità
per scoprire
scoprire nuovi linguaggi e nuove
estetiche il mio lavoro infatti consiste
nello sviluppo di software di sistemi
per poi ricercare collabora spesso con
programmatori ingegneri tante persone
nel mondo che mi aiutano a sviluppare
questi sistemi per portare avanti queste
ricerche per esempio qui una lastra
d'acciaio
un altro esempio di come nel mio lavoro
a volte la linea tra digitale e fisico
sia molto molto sottile
questa è una lastra incisa con l'analisi
di un dipinto di lavinia fontana di
giuditta law firm è però rimane come una
sorta di reliquia immaginaria un oggetto
che racconta un processo temporale e
quindi appunto nel mio lavoro la linea
tra fisico e digitale è un qualcosa che
è sottilissima e si accavalla sempre da
una parte e dall'altra proprio questo
processo di sintesi e trasformazione
realtà mi interessa a livello temporale
mi piace osservare questi oggetti come
se fossero delle reliquie appunto degli
artefatti archeologici immaginari
proprio su questo era ultimamente sto
cominciando a sperimentare su una nuova
serie questa è una foto che ho fatto ora
in studio di una tela appena appena
finita sono dei disegni preparatori in
qualche modo però risultato di un
processo di reverse engineering quindi
c'è un'analisi algoritmica di un dipinto
in questo caso l'adorazione di
botticelli poi queste informazioni
vengono tradotte e nel movimento di un
laser che brucia leggermente questa tela
come se fosse una sorta di sindone poi
impressa in questa tela ricorda però poi
il colore le vere e proprie sinopie i i
disegni preparatori come mi piace molto
di questi disegni preparatori in effetti
è che documentano un processo non sono
tanto un oggetto finito ma a documentare
un processo e per me l'apoteosi
dell'oggetto che racconta un processo
che racconta come è stato creato la sua
creazione è proprio
le statue non finita di mick e lancia
queste sono state per me una fortissima
ispirazione o qualcosa che è andato
avanti per parecchi anni non tanto
quindi l'esplorazione della figura
dell'archetipo classico ma in realtà
l'esplorazione del processo della
materia dell'articolazione della materia
dello spazio intorno a queste figure e
come e tutte le potenziali alternative
possibilità qui un piccolo video dove
alcune funzioni matematiche descrivono
appunto infinite possibilità di spazio
tra appunto la figura e il bordo di un
blocco immaginario proprio su questo
tema ha cominciato a sviluppare decine
centinaia migliaia infinite iterazioni
di nuovi a prigioni di nuovi non finiti
il focus non era appunto quello di
creare un oggetto quello di studiare
possibili alternative possibili
metodologie per ricreare questa tensione
e all'inizio pensavo questo qui
diventasse un progetto digitale
semplicemente la creazione di alcuni
video ma dopo un po mi sono reso conto
che avevano una loro qualità molto
interessante molto scultorea gli oggetti
fermi quindi ho cominciato a lavorare
con delle macchine da presa industriali
controllate anche quelle da computer
quindi cominciando a tradurre quello che
io generato con questi processi digitali
in poi dei processi fici fisici
portato avanti diverse collaborazioni
con tante società di robotica un po in
giro per il mondo che mi hanno permesso
di far girare queste sculture di fare
diverse mostre ma appunto a volte
affascinante come poi la linea tra
fisico e digitale sia così sottile in
questo caso per esempio a una mostra che
ho fatto a seul lavorando via internet
essenzialmente scolpendo dei blocchi
dall'altra parte del mondo attraverso
una connessione internet
queste queste immagini mi sa che nero
sono infatti presi e degli screenshot
presi da una skype col mentre questa
cosa avveniva andando avanti piano piano
mi sono cominciare a interessare sempre
di più del processo non tanto usando
queste macchine per generare quello che
disegnava con il computer ma realtà
semplicemente istruire le macchine e
l'estetica finale quella propria della
macchina del computer
ho cominciato a fantasticare
sull'ipotesi di poter magari fare delle
mostre dove queste sculture vengono
proprio fatte dal vivo
mi piaceva l'idea di fabbrica come se
fosse una fabbrica a di sculture bene
dopo qualche tempo dopo qualche
peripezia ci sono riuscito
quest'estate questa è la prima
installazione che sarà fatta berlino e
appunto consiste in effetti in un vero e
proprio setup robotico che sono riuscito
ad assemblare un qualcosa che poi può
essere portato in giro e mi consente di
fare queste performance installazioni in
cui vengono con scolpiti un'infinità di
pezzi
questo mentre si preparava una delle
ultime mostre invece in austria
l'altra grande fonte di ispirazione e
statella conte un altro tema che è
curioso o esplorato negli ultimi anni
parecchio da una parte nata l'idea di
lavorare con il conte
proprio su questa relazione tra due
forze contrastanti nei non finiti
michelangioleschi c'è la materia c'è la
figura in questo caso c'è il serpente ha
poi realtà quello che volevo fare era
cercare di studiare queste forze
di questa scultura e trasformarle
cambiarne la narrativa sviluppato quindi
un nuovo studio della conte oggetto che
tra l'altro è stato uno dei più studiati
nella storia dell'arte quindi
continuando l'idea e alla tradizione
dello studio della misurazione di questa
statua generando poi anche qui un
infinità di variazioni algoritmiche
degli oggetti tra l'astratto e il
figurativo cercando di calibrare questa
narrativa e creare un qualcosa nel mezzo
bene questo è una delle mie ultime
sculture che al momento è un
quadriennale a roma e in questo caso il
livello di fabbricazione livello di
dettaglio è salito molto ma non solo
anche il materiale infatti il materiale
è un marmo destrutturato essenzialmente
il materiale originale della scultura
marmo bianco viene polverizzato avviene
poi usato con una resina particolare
essenzialmente ricostruito completamente
anche il materiale è proprio primordiale
altro aspetto interessante della conte è
la storia del frammento mancante c'era
questo braccio mancante che ritrovarono
secoli dopo
in generale un po la storia di roma di
questi frammenti sparsi dappertutto che
raccontano questa doppia narrativa da
una parte c'è la narrativa della
scultura cioè cosa apparteneva quel
frammento che cos'era la cosa e quindi
su queste basi ho cominciato a studiare
altre simulazioni digitali per rompere
questo la conte e creare un'infinita di
pezzi di frammenti immaginari di questo
la conte frammenti che poi si sono
trasformati in veri e propri oggetti in
scala 1 a 1 anche qui delle reliquie
immaginarie degli oggetti che raccontano
una storia in realtà non è mai non è mai
esistita anche qui la patina sopra e poi
sarà trattata con degli acidi fatta con
una polvere di ferro quindi anche qui un
oggetto che poi
qualche modo una storia cioè stiamo
vivendo in un momento in cui c'è uno
sviluppo tecnologico incredibile che sta
cambiando il mondo ma per me il fascino
non è tanto su quello che possiamo fare
di nuovo ma quanto sta cambiando il modo
con cui noi osserviamo il mondo in un
modo o in un altro
sono affascinato proprio da queste nuove
estetiche che possono suscitare da
questi errori da questo usare la
tecnologia nel modo in cui magari non è
stata concepita il computer per me
infatti non è uno strumento per creare
le mie idee ma come se fosse un
collaboratore attraverso il quale genero
esploro queste ricerche grazie